FELIPE HOFFA: Hello everyone.
Welcome to our webinar,
Visualizing Big
Money with Big Data.
I'm Felipe Hoffa, Google
Cloud Developer Advocate.
And--
RAJ RIKHY: I'm Raj
Rikhy, Product Manager
for Cloud platforms at Bitnami.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
And today we're going
to be visualizing
big money with big data.
So let's get started.
This is live.
So if anyone has
questions, please add them.
I asked you to comment.
We will be answering them.
And if you're watching these
in the future, well, hi there.
Let's get started with this.
I have some data that's super
interesting from elections.
It's all of the
nations that have
been made open and by the FEC.
And then opensecrets.org
takes this data,
collects it, annotates
it, and leaves it
as open data on the website.
They allowed me to share
this data with you.
So I have it loaded on BigQuery.
And I have these
tables-- individual 16,
with almost five million
rows and almost two
gigabytes of data that we
would love to visualize.
That sounds good?
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: Awesome.
So with BigQuery, it's
really, really easy
to start writing sequel queries.
You don't need to
install anything.
We just need to access BigQuery.
And you can write simple queries
or complex queries like this.
Here I'm looking at how much
money each recipient got.
So simple SQL query,
five million rows.
We get the results.
We get recipients.
And now, if I want to
visualize these files,
I will need other tools.
There are plenty of tools.
But one of my favorites is--
RAJ RIKHY: Re:dash.
FELIPE HOFFA: Re:dash.
Exactly.
And to install it,
Raj here is going
to show us the best way--
a super, super way--
to get it running
on Google Cloud.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
So Re:dash is an open source
visualization and dashboarding
tool.
Bitnami is a partner of
Google Cloud Platform.
And we're going to show you
how you can launch a Bitnami
Re:dash image into your
Google Cloud Platform account.
So first, let's talk a little
bit about what our set up
and architecture looks
like for this webinar.
We're going to be using
Re:dash, as I mentioned,
to visualize the data that
we're creating with BigQuery.
Bitnami is a company that
packages mostly open source
applications and delivers
them for customers
into their configured cloud.
In this case, we're going to
use Google Cloud Platform.
Some of the advantages
of using Bitnami
are that we keep all of our
images up to date and patched.
They are cross-platform.
So you can take them locally.
You're also able to use them
anywhere else-- other platforms
as you like.
And the other important thing
to know is that Re:dash is free.
So once it provisions into your
Google Cloud Platform account,
you'll be able to use
that and SSHN as you like,
and it'll show up just as a VM.
FELIPE HOFFA: I have to say,
I really love your diagram,
because it shows
that we're going
to get elections data
from opensecrets.org
and load it into BigQuery.
We're going to read--
thanks to Bitnami--
we're going to get Re:dash
running on Compute Engine.
RAJ RIKHY: Correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: And we are
going to get both connected.
RAJ RIKHY: Right.
Felipe, could you tell us a
little bit about BigQuery?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So BigQuery is my favorite
tool to analyze data.
You can analyze terabytes
data in seconds.
You can share data
with other people
or you can keep it totally
private with the top security
standards if that's
what you want.
It's really, really easy to
get started as we just saw.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
We'll, I'm excited to take
a look at the flexibility
of Google Cloud Platform.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh.
Let's start our free trial.
So everyone gets $300
for free for 60 days
if you start your free
trial with Google Cloud.
And then you can start
trying all of these products,
platforms for free.
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
And I think with
BigQuery, you're
really only charged against
the queries that you use.
Right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So with BigQuery,
you don't need to pay
for any kind of servers, hours.
With BigQuery you just pay
for how much data you store,
how much date each of
your queries queries.
But if you're not
doing anything,
you don't need to pay
hourly or anything.
There's no servers to speak of.
It's just BigQuery, data, you.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
Really cool.
So why don't we kind
of get going here
and take a look at how we
get started for this webinar.
So the first thing
you want to do
is-- after you've created
your Google Cloud Platform
account-- we're going to jump
into the Bitnami launchpad
for Google Cloud Platform.
This is a catalog of all
the open source applications
that you have for Bitanmi.
We're going to
search for Re:dash.
We have it here.
Hit Launch.
And once we hit
Launch, it's going
to take us to the new
virtual machine page.
And we're going to go ahead
and use this configuration
to just jump in and create.
You can toggle the
server sizes and go up
if you like for more
compute or higher disk size.
And I already have
one here spun up.
So there we go.
Once you hit Create, you are
able to see the application
here.
And this is some of the
application information.
We can go to the app.
This is the info to log
in to the application.
We're going to do that here.
And boom.
We've got a running
Re:dash instance.
FELIPE HOFFA: We have
a running Re:dash.
That's perfect.
Now let's use it.
[LAUGHING[
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
Great.
So I mean obviously, we want
to use Re:dash in our existing
Google Cloud Platform account.
But it's not going
to be that helpful
unless it's connected to a
BigQuery data data set, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So how do we connect the Re:dash
you just launched to BigQuery?
RAJ RIKHY: Great question.
So let's jump in.
So we're going to hit Data
Sources inside of Re:dash,
and go to New Data Source.
And that's going to
automatically populate BigQuery
as the first item here.
FELIPE HOFFA: So it seems
like you can use Re:dash with
multiple data sources?
RAJ RIKHY: Great.
Yeah.
Yeah you're absolutely right.
So we've got-- there's MySQL.
There's Postgres.
There's Graphite.
There's even Google
Spreadsheet in here.
That's really cool.
But obviously we need
to authenticate in.
So let's generated
JSON key file.
And this is again, this is our
Google Cloud Platform console.
And I actually have
the VM running here
so you can see the activity.
What I'm going to do, is I'm
going to jump into Permissions.
It might be IM or Admin for
some of you live at home.
And we're going to
create a service account.
Let's just do Re:dash E.
Generate a private key.
FELIPE HOFFA: New
service account.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
OK.
So here it is.
And this is the project
that we launched into.
And we want the project ID
as well as the JSON key file.
So here we go.
We're going to take this
and put this in here.
We'll just call it
Re:dash BigQuery Example.
FELIPE HOFFA: Excellent.
RAJ RIKHY: Saved.
FELIPE HOFFA: Saved.
And now, you're Re:dash
is connected to BigQuery.
RAJ RIKHY: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: And if you share
that Re:dash with me-- in fact,
you already created an account
for me on your server--
RAJ RIKHY: I did.
FELIPE HOFFA: Excellent.
I can use it on my notebook.
And I can just start
writing queries.
For example, I can paste a
query I wrote here in Re:dash.
My project name is FH BigQuery.
I have my data set-- opensecrets
and the individual's database.
And this query
should bring data in.
But it didn't.
RAJ RIKHY: I think
we got an error.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
I got an error because that
dataset is not shared publicly.
I need to share it
explicitly-- in this case,
with your service account key.
And I can do that by copying
the username of the service
account.
Let me copy paste this and
bring it to the BigQuery site,
where I can look at my
dataset, share the data set.
And I can choose to share
my data with an individual
or organization
or Google Group--
in this case with
your service account.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: I
save these changes.
Now it's shared.
The resource that
you just launched,
can look at my private data.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: Now if anyone
else wants to query this data,
I will make this
also public, just
to make sure that anyone
else can look at it too.
I can share the dataset.
I can add all authenticated
users can view.
Add.
Save changes.
And now you can all
run these same queries.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
Well let's dig.
I'm really excited.
It sounds like we've got
a lot of data to dig into
and a lot of queries.
Why don't we take a look at some
of the stuff that we've got.
FELIPE HOFFA: So for
example, I created this query
in our shared Re:dash.
RAJ RIKHY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: You can
look at your computer
now at all the queries.
RAJ RIKHY: Let's take a look.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, I
need to give it a name.
Let me give it a name-- money.
Now it's saved.
Now reload.
RAJ RIKHY: Let's do this now.
Boom.
FELIPE HOFFA: Perfect.
See, now we are sharing queries.
We can do, for example,
like another visualization.
Let me add a new
visualization here,
where can get by candidate, by
the recipient ID, the column--
and now, we're looking at how
much money each candidate got.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
And if I refresh I
should be able to--
FELIPE HOFFA: Did you
get my visualizations?
Yes.
Now we're sharing a chart.
But we want to share more.
We want to share dashboards.
For that, last night I created a
dashboard in a different extent
of Re:dash.
Let me show you what I got.
Let me show you my
opensecrets dashboard.
RAJ RIKHY: Now
just a disclaimer.
We're all developers here.
We're not political pundits.
So there's definitely
insights in the data.
But we're going
to stay objective.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Let's explore data, but
let's not get very political.
OK.
So let me show you
what I got here.
My first visualization
that I got here
is how many roles
we have per month.
This is basically taking
a look at my whole dataset
of five million rows.
We can see that there was
a big jump of rows in June.
Then it dropped in July.
And then it has
been going up since.
But this shows me all
kinds of the nations.
RAJ RIKHY: Mmhmm.
FELIPE HOFFA: So then I
created this other chart,
just to look at the
presidential candidates.
RAJ RIKHY: I guess what I'm
selfishly interested in,
is to see how much each
candidate raised per month.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh.
So you want to see the money
that each candidate got.
RAJ RIKHY: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK.
So here on the left side, I got
the real money that everyone--
that we collected by month.
And then this is one
of my favorite queries.
We're looking at all
of the candidates
and how much money they got
per month-- added by month,
we can see the results.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: If you want to
see the query, just to see
how I made this happen--
RAJ RIKHY: You just hit Show
Source once you click in.
And then it pops up all the SQL.
That's awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So this query is a
little more complicated
than the previous one.
But it has the same concepts.
First, I'm looking
at the month here,
the month part of the date.
I'm looking at the recipient.
And I'm looking at adding
up all the amounts.
But then I'm doing a join
with my list of candidates.
RAJ RIKHY: Probably
you have to in order
to make the previous
chart make sense, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
So this is where I get their
names, instead of like this.
And I'm looking
only for candidates
running by President.
RAJ RIKHY: Felipe, when you
make changes on the SQL query,
does it show up on the
chart in real time?
Or what do you have to do?
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh yeah.
Let me show you.
For example, here
I'm doing a cleanup
of all the candidate that
didn't get enough donations
and on the months
that are stragglers.
But for example, if I get
rid off those filters--
RAJ RIKHY: You're just
commenting it out.
FELIPE HOFFA: And I
run my query again,
we get a completely new
updated visualization.
Ta-da.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: And this
just really shows you
why I did that cleanup.
RAJ RIKHY: [LAUGHS] There's
a lot of candidates in there.
FELIPE HOFFA: We want to
get rid of some candidates.
RAJ RIKHY: I guess Barack
Obama even raised some money.
Look.
Interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
how data works.
[LAUGHTER]
RAJ RIKHY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: It's always good
to have some cleanup filters.
And that's why I love using SQL.
I can just start
digging into this.
RAJ RIKHY: Awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: Let's go
back to the dashboard.
Any questions that you
would like answered?
RAJ RIKHY: Well, I'm
interested to see
how much the candidates raised
per month, but on both sides,
right?
So you've got the
Democratic candidates,
and then you've got the
Republican candidates, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: I have the
perfect query for you.
Basically I do the same data.
RAJ RIKHY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: And on one
side I put the Democrats.
On the other side I
put the Republicans.
RAJ RIKHY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: This
way we can see
more clearly how each candidate
progressed over the year.
RAJ RIKHY: So if you see
here, this is interesting
because it looks like
Hillary Clinton really
started out strong in terms of
aggregate value of donations.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
Do you see this
little yellow one?
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
Bernie Sanders.
That's growing donations.
RAJ RIKHY: Wow.
Up and to the right.
Look at that.
FELIPE HOFFA: Up
and to the right.
Yeah.
RAJ RIKHY: And then
last month, March, I
guess the last bar kind
of eclipsed the other one.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
RAJ RIKHY: 20 million versus 19.
That's interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: According
to the data I have here,
Bernie Sanders got more money
in March than Hilary Clinton.
And he started
really, really slow.
So it's pretty cool to see.
RAJ RIKHY: What about the
Republican candidates?
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh.
We have way more
candidates here.
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: There's
one biggest standout
donation month--
June for Jeb Bush.
RAJ RIKHY: He must have
raised a lot of money then.
FELIPE HOFFA: At
that time, not the--
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
The other ones--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RAJ RIKHY: So it was like, OK.
So there's Jeb.
And then all the
way on the right,
we have this green bar
here that stands out.
Who's that?
FELIPE HOFFA: That is Ted Cruz.
RAJ RIKHY: Huh.
FELIPE HOFFA: Not in the
race anymore, but yes.
He was really good
at raising money.
RAJ RIKHY: He raised money.
Yeah.
That's really interesting,
really interesting.
And sorry, one last question--
where's Donald Trump?
FELIPE HOFFA: Donald Trump.
He's here.
He has a very small green
bar because he did not
focus on raising--
RAJ RIKHY: I guess that
kind of make sense.
Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
RAJ RIKHY: OK.
Interesting.
What's this next
visualization about?
FELIPE HOFFA: OK.
So here it's about how much
money each candidate collected.
We can see that Hillary
Clinton got more money
than any other candidate
that shows here.
RAJ RIKHY: It does make sense
with the previous data, where
she was raising strong too.
So I guess the aggregate here on
the left-hand side make sense.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
We have here $140
million for Hillary
versus almost $3 million of
raised money for Donald Trump.
That's a huge difference.
RAJ RIKHY: It is a
pretty big difference.
What's this red line?
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh.
With this red line I
was trying to visualize
what's the average donation
that each candidate got.
RAJ RIKHY: So like
for example, if you
had a lot of really
small donations,
then that number would
be much smaller, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
So for example, the
average donation
where Hillary is $565--
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
Kind of in the
middle of the pack.
OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: Versus
Bernie Sanders
whose average donation is $140.
RAJ RIKHY: Interesting.
Where's the spike?
What is that about?
FELIPE HOFFA: This is Jeb Bush.
RAJ RIKHY: Oh OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: The
really big donations
when he was getting donations.
RAJ RIKHY: Got it.
Yeah the aggregate
average value was higher.
OK.
Interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
next visualization?
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
Sure.
FELIPE HOFFA: Industries.
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
That makes sense.
I do kind of want to see
how it gets broken down
and where they're coming from.
It looks really interesting
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
So open [INAUDIBLE]
does a good job
of looking at the
employer of each donor.
And then they categorize
this by industry.
So you can start looking at
what industries are donating
more money to each candidate.
And we can get a little
visualization like this.
I would love to go
deeper into this
but maybe we can leave
that for another webinar.
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah.
Definitely.
You know what I'm really
interested to see?
I would really like to
see the amount of money
raised per candidate.
That's the first one.
But also compared to
the number of votes.
And I mean, this is
the primaries, right?
So the number of delegates they
got-- that's the first thing.
The second thing that I'm
really interested to see
is how much they spent
per vote and per delegate.
FELIPE HOFFA: So those are
super interesting questions.
So you want to see of all the
money they raised, divide that
by the number of votes.
RAJ RIKHY: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: So I ran
that query already.
RAJ RIKHY: OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: And I have
my visualizations here.
On the left side, you can see
the ratio of votes to money.
And on the right you can see
the ratio of money to delegates.
What do I mean by this?
Basically for example,
Bernie Sanders in Kansas
raised $2,000-- almost
$3,000-- for each vote he got.
RAJ RIKHY: Wow.
That kind of makes sense.
So this is kind of
reflective of the strength
of the organizations
fundraising, and how much
resources or whatever it is that
they put into getting donations
for that state, per the
number of votes that they got.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So a smaller means
more efficient.
RAJ RIKHY: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: With less money,
they got way more votes.
RAJ RIKHY: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: You can see
that, for example, Donald Trump
raised very little money and
then he got a lot of votes.
RAJ RIKHY: True.
FELIPE HOFFA: So we can
really see that ratio here.
But what we really care
about with primaries--
RAJ RIKHY: Is delegates.
FELIPE HOFFA: Delegates.
No one knows how that works, but
they're the ones that decide.
[LAUGHTER]
Here are how much money each one
raised per state per delegate.
RAJ RIKHY: Per
state per delegate.
FELIPE HOFFA: Just to give
you a random fact point,
Ted Cruz in North Carolina
raised about $30,000
per each delegate
that he finally got.
RAJ RIKHY: Wow.
That's really interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: We can
start going deeper
into this chart
of visualizations.
RAJ RIKHY: Let's
look at expenses.
That's the one
I'm curious about.
FELIPE HOFFA: Expenses.
So instead of money donated,
it's how much money they spent.
RAJ RIKHY: To get votes and
then also to get delegates.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK.
Let's end up with that.
Here is our first visualization.
We take all the money that
each candidate got-- spent.
RAJ RIKHY: Spent.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
also open data.
We divide it by the
number of votes.
Yes. [INAUDIBLE]
basically spent 50--
RAJ RIKHY: Spent a lot of money.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, almost
$48 for each vote he got.
RAJ RIKHY: Per vote.
FELIPE HOFFA: Hillary
Clinton is at $11 per vote.
Donald Trump, $0.27 per vote.
RAJ RIKHY: A quarter
per vote, huh?
FELIPE HOFFA: Basically that's
the spending not much money
and getting a lot of votes.
RAJ RIKHY: Wow.
FELIPE HOFFA: And then of course
you want to know delegates.
RAJ RIKHY: Yes.
Because that's what
really makes a difference
I guess in primaries.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
And again we have
something that shows
that Ben Carson spent about
$4.5 million for each delegate
he got.
RAJ RIKHY: Is there a way
to clean this up so that we
can maybe see the rest of them?
It looks like the
Ben Carson's kind
of skewing the
data a little bit.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh yeah.
Let's edit this query.
I'll show you the
source of this query.
Basically the same
logic as before.
And here I'm going
to filter out Ben.
So if I can get it
to [INAUDIBLE] Ben,
we are filtering it out.
Let's visualize that.
RAJ RIKHY: Sounds good.
FELIPE HOFFA: Here we have it.
The same chart without Ben.
RAJ RIKHY: Really interesting.
Really interesting.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So you now can see
the difference.
RAJ RIKHY: That's amazing.
So how much did-- what's
the lowest number on there?
Donald Trump?
FELIPE HOFFA: Almost
$3,000 per delegate
compared to Marco Rubio's
$200,000 per delegate.
RAJ RIKHY: Wow.
FELIPE HOFFA: I just find it
so much fun just analyzing
data, asking questions.
RAJ RIKHY: That's amazing.
FELIPE HOFFA: I love
playing with this data,
sharing visualizations,
datasets, et cetera.
RAJ RIKHY: It's I
think one thing to be
able to draw intelligible
conclusions about where you're
going to be with
slicing and dicing data.
But showing it on the
screen and visualizing it
in a way that is accessible to a
lot of people is really useful.
FELIPE HOFFA: It's really,
really fun and everyone
can do it.
BigQuery is open for everyone.
Come and analyze data.
Everyone has a free terabyte
to analyze every month.
And with the free trial you can
launch your own Re:dash server.
RAJ RIKHY: And use your Bitnami
images and your Google Platform
account.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
And launch any other kind of
open source software like--
RAJ RIKHY: Yeah like WordPress,
Drupal, and the like.
So awesome.
FELIPE HOFFA: So thank you very
much for coming here today.
RAJ RIKHY: Thank
you for joining us.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Please stay curious and let's
say see you in the next video.
RAJ RIKHY: See you in the Cloud.
FELIPE HOFFA: Excellent.
RAJ RIKHY: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]